olá, meu nome é Olivia Lanes e bem-vindo de volta à Computação Quântica na Prática. Este é o episódio dois:
Quantum circuits. Vamos cobrir vários tópicos na aula de hoje, mas o que quero que você saia sabendo são as três coisas a seguir. Um: o que os computadores
quânticos da IBM realmente são, para que você tenha ao menos uma ideia geral do que está fazendo quando envia um job para um deles pela
nuvem. Dois: o que é o Qiskit, o que são Primitivas e como podemos usá-las para criar e executar quantum circuits.
Também vamos discutir em alto nível os diferentes tipos de processadores IBM Quantum disponíveis e o que distingue um do outro. E três:
por último, o fluxo de trabalho típico que seguimos para executar experimentos em escala. Isso inclui selecionar as melhores Primitivas
para o seu caso de uso, mapear um problema para um quantum circuit e aplicar supressão e mitigação de erros, que nos permitem
extrair o máximo de poder dessas máquinas. Há muita informação aqui, mas fique comigo,
porque em breve vamos juntar tudo no contexto de alguns exemplos reais. Primeiro, vamos discutir brevemente os qubits e o hardware
quântico em si. Como experimentalista, posso te garantir que é fascinante e realmente ajuda a conectar os pontos para
visualizar o que está acontecendo de verdade quando os jobs são enviados para um computador quântico pela nuvem. Os processadores
que vamos usar são construídos com qubits transmons supercondutores. Aqui está como um pequeno processador IBM Quantum
parece. Esses pequenos quadrados aqui são os qubits em si — há um total de cinco neste chip. O transmon
em si é um capacitor e consiste em duas placas de metal conectadas em paralelo com um indutor não-linear chamado de
junção Josephson. Mas para ver a junção Josephson você precisa ampliar ainda mais. Ela é criada a partir de duas
camadas sobrepostas de metal supercondutor, e onde as duas peças se sobrepõem e se tocam fica a junção. Uma junção
Josephson é um elemento que pode ser usado para criar um átomo artificial com múltiplos níveis de energia, e isolamos
os dois níveis de energia mais baixos como nosso estado de qubit. As linhas onduladas aqui representam os ressonadores de micro-ondas —
basicamente linhas de transmissão 2D acopladas ao qubit. Agora, quando programamos um gate, isso equivale essencialmente a escolher um
pulso de micro-ondas altamente calibrado, e a frequência, amplitude, forma e duração específicas desses pulsos fazem o
qubit fazer coisas específicas. As instruções para o pulso de micro-ondas vão do seu computador para a nuvem e
depois são lidas e interpretadas pela eletrônica de controle de temperatura ambiente, que pega essas instruções e gera fisicamente
os pulsos. Chamamos de pulsos de micro-ondas porque todos se encaixam dentro da faixa de frequência de micro-ondas,
que fica em torno de 1 GHz. Depois que as caixas de controle de temperatura ambiente criam os pulsos, eles viajam pelos cabos
até o refrigerador de diluição e eventualmente ao nosso chip quântico. O sinal entra nos ressonadores por meio de
um wire bond nesses pads e então flui pela linha de transmissão até nossos qubits. Sei que tudo isso pode
ter sido um pouco técnico e esses detalhes não são cruciais para entender em nosso avanço, mas espero que agora você
consiga pelo menos imaginar o sistema físico com o qual todos estão prestes a interagir. Então onde esses computadores quânticos
realmente existem? Bem, a IBM tem dezenas de computadores quânticos pelo mundo inteiro, e recentemente atualizamos nossa frota para
conter apenas processadores com mais de 100 qubits, como mencionei na lição anterior. Alguns deles estão localizados em um
data center IBM Quantum no interior do estado de Nova York. Esses sistemas estão disponíveis para todos na nuvem, e alguns
são sistemas dedicados on-premise, completos com toda a eletrônica necessária para fazê-los funcionar, que suportam nossos parceiros
na rede IBM Quantum. Agora vamos falar sobre o Qiskit, que é o kit de desenvolvimento de software de código aberto da IBM
projetado para trabalhar com computadores quânticos. Daqui em diante vou me referir a isso como o Qiskit SDK. Há também o
ecossistema Qiskit, que é uma coleção de softwares, tutoriais e funções que se baseiam ou estendem as funcionalidades principais do Qiskit, bem como o Qiskit
Runtime, que é um serviço de computação quântica e modelo de programação que permite aos usuários projetar e executar
eficientemente suas cargas de trabalho quânticas usando as Primitivas do Qiskit. Uma Primitiva é basicamente um bloco de construção pequeno que
você pode usar para projetar circuits maiores ou um job. As duas Primitivas mais importantes para nós serão o
sampler e o estimator, que discutiremos com mais detalhes em breve. Se você ainda não baixou e instalou o
Qiskit SDK, não há como um momento melhor do que agora. O Qiskit 1.0 foi lançado recentemente e está mais performático e
estável do que nunca. Então, para quem está começando, chegou no momento perfeito. Para quem já conhece o
Qiskit, será necessário baixar e reinstalar a versão mais recente. Recomendamos usar o
pip para instalar o Qiskit e o Qiskit Runtime e rodá-los em um notebook Jupyter no navegador web de sua preferência. Você também vai precisar
instalar o Jupyter Notebook ou o JupyterLab, caso ainda não tenha feito isso. Essas ferramentas são todas gratuitas e você
pode colocá-las para funcionar na sua própria máquina local sem nenhum custo. Certifique-se de adicionar o Qiskit com as
dependências de opção de visualização para que funcione com o Jupyter e te permita plotar coisas. Você também precisará configurar um ambiente Python virtual, e há
instruções de como fazer isso na página de instalação do Qiskit, linkada aqui. Depois de se familiarizar com o Qiskit e estar
pronto para executar jobs em computadores quânticos reais, precisará se registrar em quantum.ibm.com e criar um
token de API do IBM Quantum, e há também um link para isso aqui. Um guia detalhado de como fazer isso seguindo todas as
instruções na nossa página de documentação, como mencionei, ou você pode assistir ao vídeo de instalação do Qiskit aqui —
ambos estão linkados na descrição. Agora estamos quase prontos para começar a falar sobre quantum
circuits. Como o objetivo deste curso é ensinar a você, a audiência, como escalar seus jobs para serem executados em escala de 100 qubits
ou mais, acredito que o caminho mais construtivo é primeiro considerar o fluxo de trabalho geral que vamos seguir. E a maneira mais fácil de
entender um fluxo de trabalho típico de computação quântica é através dos Qiskit patterns. Os Qiskit patterns são um framework conceitual que permite aos usuários executar
cargas de trabalho quânticas implementando certas etapas com ferramentas modulares. Isso permite que as tarefas de computação quântica sejam executadas por uma
infraestrutura de computação heterogênea e poderosa. Essas etapas podem ser realizadas como um serviço e podem
incorporar gerenciamento de recursos, o que permite a composabilidade contínua de novas capacidades à medida que são desenvolvidas. Aqui
estão as principais etapas que os usuários experientes do Qiskit provavelmente já reconhecerão. A primeira etapa é o mapeamento. Essa etapa
formaliza como pegamos um problema geral que nos interessa e descobrimos como mapeá-lo em um computador quântico
na forma de um circuit. Em seguida, otimizamos. Nessa etapa, usamos o transpiler do Qiskit para rotear e fazer o layout do
circuit em um hardware quântico físico real. Isso inclui traduzir os quantum gates individuais em sequências
de operações que são executadas no hardware, bem como otimização no layout desses gates. Em seguida, vamos
executar. As Primitivas do Qiskit Runtime fornecem a interface com o hardware IBM Quantum que permite executar o circuit transpilado.
Essa etapa também inclui o uso de técnicas de supressão e mitigação de erros, que podem ser abstraídas em grande parte do usuário. Por último, fazemos o pós-processamento. Nessa
etapa, os dados do próprio processador quântico são processados, fornecendo ao usuário resultados úteis sobre o problema original. Basicamente, essa etapa
abrange qualquer análise adicional dos dados adquiridos. Agora estamos prontos para discutir a base dos programas
quânticos, que são os quantum circuits. Espero que você já esteja familiarizado com quantum circuits, mas caso não esteja, pode ser que queira primeiro conferir a lição
três, Quantum Circuits, que faz parte de "Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica", linkada abaixo. Só
vamos dar uma revisão rápida aqui. Um quantum circuit é uma rede de quantum gates e medições ligados
por fios que representam os qubits. Os quantum circuits podem ser lidos como uma partitura musical, da esquerda para a direita, começando no
tempo zero, que fica bem à esquerda. Os qubits virtuais — ou seja, qubits que ainda não foram atribuídos a um
qubit físico em um processador — são listados em ordem crescente de cima para baixo. Depois de configurar nosso circuit, podemos adicionar
gates a ele. Gates de single qubit, como este gate Hadamard aqui, afetam apenas o qubit em cujo fio estão. Gates de múltiplos qubits,
como este CNOT, afetam dois ou mais qubits ligados pelo gate. Neste exemplo, o estado do qubit 1 muda
dependendo de qual é o estado do qubit zero. Depois que todos os gates são aplicados, podemos realizar medições,
que fazem com que os resultados sejam escritos em registros clássicos. Uma característica particularmente importante de
um circuit é sua profundidade. A profundidade do quantum circuit é o número mínimo de camadas de quantum gates executados em
paralelo necessário para completar a computação definida pelo circuit. Para ficar claro, os quantum gates podem ser executados em
paralelo — ou seja, exatamente ao mesmo tempo — sempre que não tenham nenhum qubit em comum. Mas se dois ou mais
gates atuam nos mesmos qubits, não podemos executá-los em paralelo: somos forçados a executá-los um após o outro, porque os quantum gates levam tempo para serem
implementados. A profundidade de um circuit corresponde aproximadamente à quantidade de tempo necessária para os computadores quânticos executarem o
circuit. Portanto, saber a profundidade de um circuit é importante para saber se ele pode ser executado em um determinado dispositivo ou não. Isso também nos dirá se ele
tem boas chances de produzir um resultado preciso. Em seguida, vamos falar sobre a seleção de um processador quântico. A IBM
lançou recentemente uma frota totalmente nova de processadores, todos com mais de 100 qubits, e você pode acessar quantum.ibm.com para ver
quais processadores você tem acesso. Os processadores têm todos nomes de pássaros, por algum motivo, e os diferentes logos
representam diferentes tipos de processadores. Por exemplo, esses aqui representam processadores Eagle, e esse ícone é um
Heron. Os nomes específicos dos processadores também são encontrados no topo — todos têm nomes de cidades, mas isso
não significa necessariamente que o processador está fisicamente localizado naquela cidade. São apenas nomes. A contagem de qubits,
EPLG e CLOPS são também fatores que aparecem listados. Vamos passar por cada um deles.
Qubits: isso é bem autoexplicativo. Qubits é apenas o número total de qubits disponíveis para uso naquele processador ou
QPU. EPLG significa erros por gate em camada, que mede o erro médio do processo de gate em uma cadeia em camadas de
100 qubits. Basicamente, você quer que seja o menor possível. CLOPS significa circuit layer operations per second e
mede quantas camadas de um quantum volume circuit — que é um circuit virtual — um QPU pode executar por unidade de tempo.
Quanto maior o número, mais rápido podemos computar. Isso é equivalente ao que FLOPS significa na computação clássica.
Essas diferentes métricas podem ser mais ou menos importantes dependendo da área de aplicação específica que você está interessado. Em seguida, vamos discutir em alto nível
o mapeamento para quantum circuits. O primeiro passo é a etapa de mapeamento, que essencialmente responde à pergunta: como
traduzo meu problema em um quantum circuit que possa ser executado em hardware quântico? Não há dúvida:
mapeamento é um problema difícil e é uma área ativa de pesquisa. Às vezes, apenas ser capaz de pegar um problema computacional
e elaborar uma sequência de quantum gates que ajude a resolvê-lo é a parte mais difícil. Não há um método infalível
que garanta sucesso, mas há diretrizes recomendadas e exemplos de problemas que já sabemos como
mapear. A primeira diretriz é deixar os computadores clássicos fazer o trabalho que eles fazem melhor. Tarefas
fáceis para computadores clássicos provavelmente não se beneficiarão de um computador quântico. Computadores quânticos são para problemas que são classicamente difíceis.
Claro, se esta é sua primeira vez usando o Qiskit ou um computador quântico, não se preocupe em encontrar um problema computacionalmente complexo. Quebre-o
em problemas menores que você possa aprender a resolver antes de ir direto para um projeto em escala de utilidade. Em seguida, traduza os
resultados do seu problema que você quer medir ou entender em um problema de valor esperado ou um problema de
amostragem. Para a maioria dos tipos de problemas, isso corresponde essencialmente a calcular uma função de custo. Uma função de custo é uma
função específica do problema que define o objetivo do problema como algo a ser minimizado ou maximizado, e pode ser
usada para ver quão bem um estado ou solução de teste está se saindo em relação a esse objetivo.
Essa noção pode ser aplicada a várias aplicações em química, aprendizado de máquina, finanças, otimização e assim por diante.
Tenha também em mente que o hardware que você vai usar tem uma topologia específica. Alguns qubits não estão conectados,
outros estão, e no final você precisará mapear seu problema para um circuit que represente isso. Os processadores IBM Quantum
usam o que chamamos de topologia heavy hex, que essencialmente equivale a conexões de qubits em uma rede hexagonal,
na qual entraremos mais adiante no curso. Por enquanto, o mais importante a ter em mente é que esta etapa requer
prática. Você precisa ter um bom entendimento não só do seu problema, mas também das capacidades do
hardware quântico, e vamos passar por um exemplo específico e caso de uso mais adiante para ver como esses podem ser melhor
equilibrados. Agora vamos discutir como otimizar um circuit para o hardware que selecionamos. O objetivo geral da
etapa de otimização é mapear todos os qubits virtuais do nosso circuit para qubits reais em algum lugar na
topologia do processador. O nome do jogo é reduzir erros o máximo possível. Para fazer isso, precisamos primeiro
rotear e fazer o layout do nosso circuit eficientemente. A primeira coisa a ter em mente é que nem todos os qubits estão conectados —
como já disse, alguns estão na verdade bem distantes uns dos outros no chip. Então precisamos reduzir ou eliminar interações de longa
distância sempre que possível. Você pode aplicar uma sequência de swap gates entre qubits vizinhos para mover a
informação dos qubits, mas os swap gates são custosos e propensos a erros, então pode haver maneiras melhores de fazer isso.
O layout e o roteamento são processos iterativos e atribuem um qubit virtual do seu circuit ao qubit físico no
hardware. Você pode fazer isso manualmente, mas há também ferramentas no Qiskit que podem fazer recomendações para o layout de
qubits físicos com base em taxas de erro aproximadas. Em seguida, podemos compor sequências de gates de single qubit atuando no mesmo qubit
em gates únicos, e às vezes também podemos eliminar gates desnecessários ou combinações de gates. Por exemplo,
algumas combinações de gates podem ser reduzidas a combinações mais simples, e às vezes combinações de gates até mesmo
equivalem a apenas um operador identidade simples, então podemos simplesmente eliminá-las. Você pode fazer isso automaticamente usando o
transpiler do Qiskit, ou pode fazer manualmente gate a gate se tiver um bom motivo para isso e quiser
mais controle. Depois de melhorar o layout do circuit, o roteamento e as contagens de gates, seja manualmente ou usando o transpiler do Qiskit,
geralmente queremos visualizar nosso circuit para garantir que o timing de todos os gates faça sentido. Há um argumento que você pode sinalizar no transpiler para
visualizar a linha do tempo do seu circuit e garantir que tudo esteja alinhado como você esperaria. Agora vamos falar sobre supressão
de erros. A supressão de erros se refere a várias técnicas que transformam um circuit durante a compilação para minimizar erros.
É diferente da mitigação de erros, que acontece depois que o circuit já foi executado — e chegaremos nisso em breve. As duas formas mais comuns de
supressão de erros das quais nos aproveitamos são o decoupling dinâmico e o twirling de Pauli. Haverá alguns
detalhes técnicos aqui, mas você sempre pode consultar isso depois. Então, primeiro: o decoupling dinâmico é usado para
cancelar efetivamente parte do ruído que afeta o qubit, aplicando uma série de gates que juntos somam à
operação identidade, como sequências XX, cujo efeito líquido é aproximadamente cancelar os canais de ruído que afetam
o qubit. O twirling de Pauli é uma forma de inserir gates aleatórios para simplificar o ruído médio. A aleatoriedade ajuda a
evitar que os efeitos de diferentes erros se acumulem tão rapidamente e também torna o ruído mais fácil de caracterizar.
Agora, esse método também forma a base de uma técnica de mitigação de erros, e vamos discutir isso mais tarde.
Novamente, há muita informação aqui e não se preocupe se nem tudo entrar de primeira. Felizmente, muito disso pode ser feito automaticamente usando o Qiskit
transpiler. A transpilação pode ser complicada, mas é uma etapa tão crucial para atingir a utilidade em escala
que requer muito de tentativa e erro para ser dominada e obter os melhores resultados. Agora quero fazer um breve
interlúdio para discutir o transpiler do Qiskit e suas capacidades com um pouco mais de detalhe. Farei isso em alto nível e vamos entrar nos detalhes e ver
alguns exemplos mais adiante. Em geral, a transpilação é o processo de reescrever um circuit de entrada para corresponder à
topologia e ao dispositivo quântico específico e otimizar o circuit para execução e resiliência contra ruído. Também
reescreve um circuit para os gates de base daquele processador quântico específico que você selecionou para usar. O Qiskit tem quatro
pipelines de transpilação integrados e, a menos que você já esteja familiarizado com otimização de quantum circuits, definitivamente recomendo usar um desses
pipelines integrados. Por padrão, o transpiler inclui estas seis etapas: inicialização,
layout, roteamento, tradução, otimização e agendamento. Inicialização se refere a
qualquer passe inicial que seja necessário antes de começarmos a embutir o circuit no backend. Isso geralmente envolve
desdobrar instruções personalizadas e converter o circuit em gates de um e dois qubits. A etapa de layout aplica
um mapeamento de layout dos qubits virtuais no circuit para os qubits físicos em um backend. O roteamento é executado depois que um layout foi
aplicado e injeta gates como swap gates no circuit original para torná-lo compatível com a
conectividade do backend. A quarta etapa é a tradução: nessa etapa, os gates do circuit são traduzidos para o
conjunto de bases do backend alvo. Em seguida, vem a otimização. Essa etapa executa o loop
principal de otimização repetidamente até que uma condição seja atendida, como atingir uma certa profundidade alvo. Temos quatro níveis diferentes de otimização
para escolher. Por último, há o agendamento: essa etapa é para quaisquer passes de agendamento cientes do hardware. Em alto nível, o agendamento
pode ser considerado como inserir atrasos no circuit para contabilizar qualquer tempo ocioso nos qubits
entre a execução de instruções. Então, como disse, há quatro níveis de otimização, variando de 0 a três, onde
níveis de otimização mais altos levam mais tempo e esforço computacional, mas você pode acabar com um circuit melhor.
O nível de otimização zero é destinado a experimentos de caracterização de dispositivos e, como tal, apenas mapeia o circuit de entrada para
as restrições do backend alvo. Ele não realiza nenhuma otimização. O nível de otimização três
dedica o maior esforço para otimizar o circuit. Porém, como muitas das técnicas de otimização no
transpiler são baseadas em heurísticas, dedicar mais esforço computacional nem sempre resulta em uma melhoria
na qualidade do circuit de saída. Se isso for de seu interesse, confira as páginas do transpiler na documentação do
Qiskit, linkada abaixo. Agora estamos prontos para discutir a execução real de um quantum circuit.
As Primitivas do Qiskit Runtime fornecem uma interface com o hardware IBM Quantum e também abstraem a supressão e
mitigação de erros do usuário. A primitiva sampler retorna a distribuição de quase-probabilidade ou contagens
representando a probabilidade de medir certas strings de bits, zeros e uns. A primitiva estimator retorna os valores esperados
de observáveis correspondentes a quantidades físicas. Então, em um pouco mais de detalhe: o sampler executa o circuit
várias vezes em um dispositivo quântico, realizando medições em cada execução e construindo a distribuição de
probabilidade a partir da recuperação dessas strings de bits. Quanto mais execuções ou shots ele realizar, mais precisos os resultados
serão, mas isso requer mais tempo. Os recursos quânticos necessários para executar isso calculam especificamente a
probabilidade de obter cada possível estado da base padrão medindo o estado preparado pelo circuit. O
estimator do Qiskit usa um processo algébrico complexo para estimar o valor esperado em um dispositivo quântico real,
decompondo o observável em uma combinação de outros observáveis que têm bases próprias conhecidas e executando. Por baixo
dos panos das Primitivas estão as técnicas chamadas de mitigação de erros. Mitigação de erros é um termo guarda-chuva para tudo isso e
basicamente se refere às técnicas que nos permitem reduzir erros do circuit modelando o ruído do dispositivo no momento da
execução. Isso geralmente resulta em sobrecarga de pré-processamento quântico relacionada ao treinamento do modelo e sobrecarga de
pós-processamento clássico para mitigar erros nos resultados brutos usando um modelo gerado. Mas em troca dessa
sobrecarga, conseguimos obter resultados muito mais precisos. Há várias técnicas que podemos implementar para a
mitigação de erros e vamos detalhar três delas. Esteja ciente, no entanto, de que esta é uma área de
pesquisa ativa, então novas técnicas provavelmente serão inventadas e as mais antigas continuarão sendo aprimoradas. O
nível de resiliência aumenta o custo, ou seja, o tempo necessário para executar seu job. Já dissemos que no
nível de resiliência zero, o transpiler na verdade não faz nada com seu circuit. Mas a partir do nível de resiliência um, ele introduz um método chamado T-REx —
Twirled Readout Error eXtinction. O T-REx usa twirling de Pauli para
mitigar ruído, algo que já abordamos. É uma técnica muito geral e eficaz que,
intuitivamente falando, torna o ruído menos irregular e mais fácil de lidar. A partir do nível de resiliência dois,
introduzimos a extrapolação de ruído zero, ou ZNE. Esta é uma técnica popular com a qual tivemos muito
sucesso recentemente. A ideia por trás da ZNE pode ser um pouco surpreendente: na verdade adicionamos ruído
adicional sobre o que já existe, mas o que isso faz é nos permitir extrapolar na direção inversa para
prever como seriam os resultados se houvesse menos ruído. Isso pode ser feito de várias maneiras específicas. Por exemplo,
podemos esticar os gates para torná-los mais longos e, portanto, mais propensos a erros, ou podemos executar mais gates que no final
resultam em uma operação identidade, então o circuit na verdade não muda funcionalmente, mas amostramos deliberadamente mais
ruído. Você tem que fazer isso para cada circuit e cada valor esperado que quer rastrear, então
dá pra ver como pode ficar muito caro em termos do tempo necessário. Um tipo específico de ZNE é chamado de
amplificação probabilística de erros, ou PEA. Depois de aprender um modelo de ruído para um gate, a PEA funciona amostrando
erros desse modelo de ruído e deliberadamente os injetando no circuit. Como mencionei, muitas novas
técnicas continuam a ser desenvolvidas e esperamos que sejam implementadas à medida que aparecem cada vez mais. Há apenas uma forma final de
mitigação de erros que quero discutir, chamada cancelamento probabilístico de erros. Em vez de estar no terceiro nível de resiliência,
a PEC é uma capacidade especial que você precisa ativar manualmente no Qiskit, porque os recursos computacionais
necessários para ela não escalam muito bem comparado às outras técnicas de mitigação de erros que discutimos. Você
começa aprendendo sobre o ruído que afeta seu circuit executando circuits de aprendizado de ruído ou caracterização de ruído
para cada camada única de gates de dois qubits presentes no seu circuit. Esses resultados permitem descrever o ruído
em termos de operadores de Pauli. Depois de conhecer esses termos de ruído, você pode modificar seus circuits para
que eles efetivamente tenham a PEC oposta integrada para cancelar esses canais de ruído. De certa forma, esse processo é
semelhante ao de fones de ouvido com cancelamento de ruído. Porém, essa forma de desfazer o ruído é muito custosa, com um tempo de
execução que cresce exponencialmente com o número de gates, então pode não ser a melhor escolha para um circuit muito grande. Chegamos
agora à etapa final: pós-processamento. No final, se você tiver feito um bom trabalho e empregado técnicas adequadas de mitigação
de erros, você pode ver sua resposta final mudar, como nesta figura aqui. Uma distribuição não mitigada,
mostrada em roxo, está bem distante do verdadeiro valor esperado, mostrado aqui por essa linha. Porém, depois que aplicamos nossa mitigação
de erros, obtemos uma distribuição mitigada, mostrada em azul, que tem um pico muito mais próximo ao valor verdadeiro. Agora,
tudo isso tem um custo, e aqui podemos ver que a variância ou a largura da distribuição aumentou, o que
geralmente não é o que você quer. Mas tudo tem um custo. Felizmente, podemos compensar isso executando mais
shots, o que faz a distribuição voltar a um nível aceitável de incerteza. Então é isso para esta
lição. Para a próxima, vamos pegar todas essas etapas e juntá-las para trabalhar em uma área e em um exemplo
de interesse aplicado real. Há algumas coisas que posso recomendar que façamos até lá. Se ainda não tiver feito,
certifique-se de baixar e configurar o Qiskit 1.0. Você também pode conferir a lição associada para este capítulo e
o episódio anterior na IBM Quantum Learning Platform. E por último, se você tiver interesse em se aprofundar mais e
aprender mais sobre técnicas de mitigação de erros, confira uma das numerosas fontes que linkei abaixo. Até lá, nos vemos na próxima vez.
[Música]